Der berühmte Aachener Dom
erstrahlt im Licht.
Denn das Wahrzeichen der Stadt
hat ein besonderes Jubiläum:
Vor vierzig Jahren wurde es als
erstes Bauwerk Deutschlands
von der UNESCO
zum Weltkulturerbe erklärt.
Am Eröffnungsabend ist es
kalt und regnerisch,
doch das verdirbt den Besuchern
nicht die Stimmung.
Ein Jahr lang hat Lichtdesigner Christoph
Hillen an diesem Projekt gearbeitet.
Also, es ging darum,
jetzt im Rahmen dieser Festwoche
für 40 Jahre Weltkulturerbe
vom Dom darzustellen,
wie der Dom immer Gefahren ausgesetzt ist
im Laufe seiner 1200 Jahre
und wie die Aachener ihn immer
wieder gerettet haben jetzt.
Das ist natürlich alles ein bisschen
künstlerisch dann interpretiert.
Für die 3-D-Lichteffekte
sorgen 14 Projektoren
und die sogenannte Pixel-Mapping-Technik.
Es ist halt ein dreidimensionales Bild –
halt nur die Vorderseite, die wir sehen.
Die ist eingescannt worden
mit ‘nem Laserscanner.
Das heißt, wir haben wirkliche 3-D-Daten.
Wir wissen von jedem Punkt, in welcher
Entfernung von hier zum Beispiel der ist.
Und mit diesem Wissen,
wo welcher Punkt ist,
können wir dann eben mit anderen
Softwaren den Inhalt bauen,
der genau [an] das Gebäude
angepasst ist.
Über Jahrhunderte wuchs der Aachener
Dom zu seiner heutigen Gestalt.
Der älteste Teil ist die Pfalzkapelle
aus dem achten Jahrhundert.
Karl der Große hatte
die mittelalterliche Kapelle
als Teil seiner Kaiserpfalz
errichten lassen.
Sie ist alles, was von der Residenz
des sogenannten „Vater[s] Europas“
übrig geblieben ist.
Und sie ist seine letzte Ruhestätte.
Es ist schon eine Voraussetzung,
wenn man einen solchen Status
„Welterbe“ hat,
dass das Bauwerk auch erhalten bleibt
und dass auch die Stadt dafür sorgt,
dass es beispielsweise Schutzzonen
rings um den Dom gibt,
dass es keine Hochhäuser gibt,
die dann in der Sichtachse
des Aachener Doms liegen,
aber da wir haben den Eindruck, dass
da die Stadt auch sehr darauf achtet,
dass der Aachener Dom diesen
Status „Weltkulturerbe“ erhält.
Das Besondere ist natürlich,
dass hier im Aachener Dom
im Mittelalter über 30 Könige
dann auch gekrönt worden sind.
Wir haben oben im Hochmünster
... haben wir den Karlsthron,
der auch von ... höchstwahrscheinlich von
Karl dem Großen errichtet worden ist.
Im September 1978 wurde aber nicht nur
der Dom zum Welterbe ernannt,
sondern auch das ihn umgebende
Zentrum der historischen Stadt.
Ein bis zwei Millionen Euro kostet es jedes
Jahr, die Kathedrale instand zu halten.
Zurück auf dem Katschhof vor dem Dom –
gleich soll die Lichtshow beginnen.
Christoph Hillen führt die letzten
technischen Checks durch,
und dann geht es los.
Die Geschichte des Doms zieht als
Lichtspektakel an den Zuschauern vorbei.
Dem Publikum scheint es zu gefallen.
Es war genial. Es war genial, weil ...
Also, man hat ja den Dom,
den sieht man eigentlich so jeden Tag,
und hier wird er noch mal richtig präsent,
in allen Facetten, die auch die Geschichte
des Domes letztendlich widerspiegeln.
Ich kannte die Geschichte vorher nicht,
natürlich die einzelnen Bestandteile,
das kennt man schon, und es war
einfach fantastisch, ja.
Also, ich sag‘ mal, die Einbauten mit Feuer
und so was waren schon beeindruckend echt.
Ja, es hat mir sehr viel Spaß gemacht auf
jeden Fall, das sich mal so anzugucken.
Also, hat sich voll gelohnt. Wetter
war egal. Hier regnet‘s immer!
Nein, nein, das ist wirklich
sehr gut gelaufen.
Aber das war sehr fruchtbar,
so die ganze Ideenfindung
und die Arbeit daran ...
Hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Seit vielen Jahrhunderten
ist der Aachener Dom
ein beliebtes Ziel
von Millionen von Pilgern.
Und auch an diesem Festabend
ist er ein echter Besuchermagnet.